president biden's rough day on capitol
hill comes as the u.s crossed another
grim milestone in the coronavirus
pandemic overnight the nation recorded
its 700 000 death from covet 19. this is
the weekly number of cases is falling
nationwide nearly 27 percent since early
september 65 of eligible americans are
now fully vaccinated that is helping the
drive to implement vaccine mandates
michael george is here with the very
latest michael good morning michelle
good morning there are signs that the
vaccine effort is working vaccinations
are up and cases are down and as more
businesses require employees to get the
shot there's more and more evidence
workers are choosing to get vaccinated
rather than face unemployment the u.s is
now vaccinating people at the rate of
nearly three-quarters of a million shots
a day and in new york city unvaccinated
school workers are under pressure that's
about 20 percent of nearly 4 600 school
safety agents who are not vaccinated and
not eligible to work beginning monday
the mayor needs to understand that we
all feel very much betrayed the mayor
says he has 5 thousand vaccinated
replacement workers ready we are
announcing here today across the country
more hardball california's governor will
require school children to add covid to
the list of required vaccines when the
fda approves it for kids
a statewide requirement for in-person
instruction for all of our children to
add to a well-established list
that currently includes 10 vaccinations
some parents in san francisco seem to
like the idea
i can't wait i've been waiting for
vaccines for my son that's the biggest
concern we have today is
sending him to school without a vaccine
in conservative parts of southern
california i don't trust the vaccine and
i'm not going to give it to my child but
at northern iowa state biology professor
steve o'cain was suspended for asking
his students to wear masks
my disciplinary action
i hope you noticed
and
mainly
punishes not me
it punishes our students meanwhile drug
company merck announced its experimental
pill malnupiravir reduced the risk of
hospitalization by 50 percent with no
deaths in patients with mild to moderate
symptoms the company plans to file an
emergency use authorization request with
the fda to administer the drug
this is quite impactful data that we
hope
offers a little ray of hope during this
dark time of the pandemic
now let's talk about kids because every
parent is going to be facing this issue
now california is the first state to
require statewide that all public school
kids will be vaccinated but this isn't
going to take effect until likely july
of next year because it has to be fully
approved by the fda and it's likely
going to face court challenges as well
some cities in california have already
mandated these vaccinations for schools
just not the whole state overall that's
right all right michael thank you very
much